you get an actual physical reaction from
it I'm not getting turned on I'm just
relaxing we both kinda like participate
in each other's guilty pleasures like
it's never of course of like shame ASMR
auto sensory meridian response it's like
the equivalent to having a glass of wine
for me after dating natto for eight
years we found out that we love just
trying out different foods just a chance
on food we just have to try it yeah I
can't judge until you try it I want it
on the home alone I like to dance in
America I tried ethnic in the bath to
get up and dance with me I'm like come
on let's do it what you know go for it
no I made you your own personal ASMR
video right here
oh my gosh we have some cheese's for you
to try and some food to try what those
that cheese okay oh hey plug that in
okay so that's a chicken oh nice today
I'll be joining you and we both have
weird dancing if we want to do this so
this is nice
ASMR you just beauty makeover
[Music]
[Music]
really good that is that is totally in
tandem with like the personal attention
video hosting my Fisher Todd you got to
do with nacho cheese so romantic
Jasper's ready yeah
reveal yourself reveal yourself and love
yourself so I'm looking at myself and I
do mommy see this is what is good
triggers that's what you're going for
that's going to trigger their like
physical response and really get you
super relaxed I feel like this could be
like a grilled cheese thing that's there
this is the best if you don't get it now
the mare is all about loving yourself a
wink and exemple your back so close go
back oh there you go on a much I liked
it I liked so much actually do you feel
a little bit triggered it gave me a
better understanding to like what the
redeeming quality isn't it but also that
it has like a therapeutic thanks for
joining us with me yeah thank you
I am definitely cheesed out for today
she doesn't make everything better
sadly I can't believe I did the best in
the world but I'm having you Jordan yeah
yeah we published shackled at any time
I loved it at it was occur you know the
element of it now I'm not sure I don't
feel so guilty about my pleasure
okay
[Music]
a couple set you together stay together
that okay I don't think that's a